Le Hater, c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui fête son anniversaire avec sa famille et ses amis
Et qui leur parle d'un commentaire qu'il a reçu sur une de ses vidéos
Un commentaire haineux, forcément.
Et ensuite, il apprend à tout le monde qu'en fait c'est forcément quelqu'un dans cette pièce qui a pu laisser ce commentaire.
" - Que seuls ceux qui sont présents dans cette pièce ont pu...
faire plein de choses, et notamment...
- Se masturber ?
*rires*
Comme beaucoup de gens sur Internet, je reçois des commentaires en tous genres
Dont des commentaires haineux
Du coup je me suis dit "Mais pourquoi c'est aussi normal, sur Internet, en fait ?"
On est sur le tournage de "Le Hater"
Pour l'instant ça se passe très bien, je suis vraiment avec des tueurs
T'es un tueur, toi !
Même toi t'es un tueur !
*bruits de chute*
Moi j'ai adoré ce casting
Catherine et Nicolas qui viennent de la Comédie Française
Bon, bah, Ludovik, voilà, c'est la famille
Claudette, qu'on ne présente plus, hein, c'est la grand-mère de Technophobe
C'était super, aussi, d'avoir Justine Le Pottier dedans
Je voulais vraiment quelqu'un qui soit assez crédible
Sur le tournage, franchement, j'ouvre la porte et je la vois en larmes, et tout, donc du coup, même moi, j'ai EUUUH *bruit d'étonnement*
Enfin, j'étais... moi-même un petit peu ému, quoi...
Ce qui n'arrive jamais sur mes tournages, hein, dans "Les Réunions", par exemple
Quand Ludovik vomit sur la table, bon...
*vomit*
Voilà, peu... peu de larmes aux yeux, quoi...
Pour moi, la surprise, c'était vraiment Jimmy Labeuu qui était vraiment super à l'aise sur le tournage
Et puis il a impressionné un peu tout le monde, je pense !
"- J'ai un rôle très important, c'est à dire, voilà, Cyprien passe devant...
Et je joue le frère... rebelle, un petit peu
Voilà...
Ça va être génial... superbe génial... ARRÊTE !"
Il fallait faire un nombre de plans, mais... incalculables
Avec des serrés et des larges, des moyens, mon point de vue, des points de vue quand je suis debout...
C'est Théo qui a réalisé... Je me sens vachement à l'aise avec ce duo, avec Théo parce que...
Lui, il va être plus sur la technique et le rythme
Et moi, je vais me concentrer, du coup plus sur les acteurs
Et sur vraiment ce qui doit être dit, comment, ce que ça raconte
Y a eu quelques petites scènes de bêtisier...
Faut savoir que Ludo propose énormément de conneries sur le tournage
"- Attendez, attendez, excusez-moi, excusez-moi... j'aimerais porter un toast NON je rigole..."
*rires*
"Ferme ta gueule j'ai faim putain !"
"- C'est toi, Nicolas !
- Oui, c'est moi, Nicolas, enchanté..."
"- Je viens... gentiment... alors que j'ai eu une gastro entérite, je vous passe les détails, mais euh...
*rires*
- On va... on va couper..."
Avec cette scène où je découvre... Pauline, la porte grinçait, mais avec un bruit... un nouveau bruit de grincement, on n'a jamais entendu ce bruit de toute la vie...
*grincements*
Tout le monde était mort de rire, donc c'était super dur... T'avais Justine, derrière, en larmes *rire*
Qui essayait... voilà, de rester dans son perso...
Et moi, j'ouvrais la porte, et là c'était super dur
*grincements*
"- Je suis désolée..."
"- Tu te marres, Théo *rires*"
"- Allez..."
*grincements*
"- *rires* Tu sais quoi, dégage..."
"- *rires*" ça va être compliqué, à partir de là..."
Ce phénomène de haine sur Internet, totalement dédouané et totalement assumé, je trouve ça fascinant
Parce que... sous couvert d'anonymat on peut être tenté
Moi, quand j'étais gamin, j'allais sur des forums de Matt Pokora, et je... je... *rires*
Il est vrai... j'ai laissé quelques messages qui n'étaient pas très polis...
Tout le monde l'a fait, je l'ai fait... J'ai arrêté, depuis, hein ! *rires*
"- Eh ben... Mais c'est une fin de tournage ! OUAIS !
*musique*
À BIENTÔT !